moi suisse m dans la vie je suis dj dj
alpa tu vois si vous avez déjà entendu
parler peut-être lassé mais dit jeff
willy et moi on est potes depuis
toujours un jour jeff a voulu renouer
avec son île d'origine
la corse est quoi ce navet tarn et 2d
plutôt qu'aux fume un peu cette semaine
soit l'autre est bon avait lâché tout ça
bon arrêter la fumette en jamaïque ici
alors pourquoi il ya un noir sur le
drapeau corse n'a jamais parlé d'hôtel
mais dit on va quand qu on va faire du
camping
ouais donc celle qui fait le film
mouvement est pris pour un berbère la
hyène discothèque à trois kilomètres on
va aller dans cette voie un truc francis
et je m'appelle pas de francis mme le
canon regardez moi ces marcheurs on
n'est pas encore sauvés en irlande c'est
pas ici sont tournés brève un bond de
petits enfants et pas réussi à devenir
sérieux je ressemble à quoi la candeloro
les mecs je vous préviens pas de photos
pas de facebook à l'égard pas de risque
pas de réseau et resserrer les grandes
concurrentes et réussir sa vie en
travaillant sur paris ce à quoi
travaille encore c'est raté sa vie
c'était bon rythme
c'est 30 millions d'amis ici en fait
c'est ce vol dont il est une petite
bosse aux pattes a surtout annoncé pas
parce que vous avez des qataris au psg
que tout est permis
ils ont atteint surtout maintenant tous
arrêtés pour paris
c'est une galère a récemment gelé choper
ces cons de francis prenons mes chiens
dont mais mois s'appelle ben omar et
fred mars et le mois et non c'est le
blanc
as tu vois le nom à nous non c'est pas
été trop petit
regardez ce que j'ai trouvé en cherchant
du bois du manioc avec nous pas un koh
lanta encore sur peu de manioc etc des
maniaques qu'on a mis des corses le bien
sûr qu'il écorche c'est plus court de
tous les corps de la seine saint denis
entre nous on l'appelle le napoléon du
loft roanne